Fisherman rib is a comfortable, stretchy,
wide, fabric that's created
by tucking stitches
when you're doing double bed knitting.
It's reversible, making it a great
choice for scarves and shawls.
The needle setup is 1x1 ribbing.
Get started by casting on 1x1
with a Cast on that's
really stretchy and loose.
Set your ribber to tuck in one direction
and the main bed to tuck
in the opposite direction.
This way, with each pass of the carriage,
one bed will knit while
the other bed will tuck.
Be sure and bind off loosely.
You'll be pleasantly surprised at the
texture and the width of this fabric.
Would you like to learn
more about your ribber?
Please look for the Knit It Now home study
course called Ribber Basics Boot Camp.
Learn to make more beautiful fabrics like
this Fisherman Rib plus lots, lots more.
Master your ribbing with Knit it Now.